the Jo Rogan Experience like there's
certain guys like Max Holloway doesn't
even Spar he just fights he says I know
how to fight I don't want to get beat up
in the gym and go into a fight
compromised he goes I want to go in a
fight 100% so I don't even Spar he just
does drills and you know he's one of the
best alive but then there guys like Sean
Strickland that Spar constantly do you
see his house car broken into yeah pull
that video up what a wrong house to
break
into out of all the houses out of all
the houses to [__] with that guy UFC
middleweight champion who is a gun nut
yeah and really knows how to use guns
yeah out of all the guys yeah trains me
you see every photo that he has he does
YouTube videos just's [__] ARS on the
wall behind him like he's not [__]
around kids he's ready he's hilarious
that guy is he's hilarious hilarious
he's very funny he's like he's so
marketable as like an anti-hero but also
a hero you know he's a guy like so here
go to the volume give me some
volume so this is drunk guy and he's
outside Sea's apartment Sean sees
him it's a music
[Music]
play see he throws the guy down on the
ground points a gun at
him and he's standing on
him I don't know what the guy was doing
it seems like the guy was just
obliterated drunk and he thought the guy
was trying to rob him but I think the
guy was just shitfaced and he was like
looking for his keys or something what
was he doing says he was arrested oh he
hit a curb okay so so he was driving
drunk uh he stomped out a girl oh my god
oh a security guard saw him stomp out a
girl he jumped into his car and drove
off security followed him he hit a curb
completely shredded his tire drove on
the rim for a while then jumped out and
tried to hide at Sean Strickland's house
oh gosh yeah
whoops wrong dude wrong that's that's
Karma that is the universe sending you
to the wrong
spot the gravitational PLL this to Sea's
house he was such a cun he was such a
[__] that the Universe guided him to the
absolute worst place he could ever be
while he just did those things stomped
out a girl drove drunk smashed his car
into a curb ditched it tried to hide at
absolute wrong
spot like that guy's social media like
has got to be some of the most
entertaining social media oh he's
hilarious and he's a champion so it's
like he's behaving like a wild young
Contender but he's the number one guy on
earth I mean looken it's hard to say
look people can say what they want about
that osna fight oh Izzy wasn't himself
dude he wasn't himself because he got
clipped with a bomb of a right hand
strick round Strickland connected with
picture right rocked Izzy and then hit
him with how many shots that he hit him
with afterwards 8 10 Clean shots to the
Head left hooks in the clinch I mean of
course he wasn't himself after that you
get hit like that in a fight you're fuv
for the rest of those he probably
doesn't remember those rounds he fought
five rounds compromised who knows how
dinged up he got only he knows only Izzy
knows how bad he got hurt in that first
round but when you get rocked that way
and your legs give out and you go down
like Izzy did that's a concussion kids
you got rocked that's a real getting
rocked that guy did that so you could
talk all the [__] you want you know
because Strickland seems like he's got
this awkward style and people think he's
not as good as he is but you watch him
tune dudes up you're like that guy's a
[__] man out of all you know he
spars more than anybody in the UFC and
they put a mouthpiece piece that
measures how many times you get hit he
gets hit less than
anyone seriously got phenomenal defense
man holy [__] phenomenal defense his his
distance management is off the charts
and it's because he's constantly
sparring so like that's what he does
better than anybody he fights and when
he spars if you've seen the videos of
him sparring he's [__] fighting
you're fighting him yeah guy like boxers
coming and talk [__] he beats the [__]
out of them with just boxing he's
[__] dangerous man so the universe
LED that guy to that man's
house that's like perfect karmic Justice
oh it's beautiful for a guy who Stomps
out a girl and then drives drunk and
Treads his car and tries to run that is
the absolute perfect way and then it's
all on camera it's amazing yeah it's the
universe sometimes it delivers yeah
sometimes there's an opening and that
[__] wounded
gazelle wanders into Sean Strickland's
house you [__] victim
yeah that [__] of a
gazelle God every now and then yeah
every now and then the universe will
give us one of those yeah and thank God
you know what I mean yeah yeah it's good
it's good that those but again that's
the right to keep in bare arms that's
that's Freedom that's like the ability
to protect yourself he didn't know who
the [__] that guy was what if that guy
was a
creep